Indicador PS1 I Brother Knows Home
cada año es su día sobre akiro
Marca el día en que la humanidad
suelta todos tus recursos naturales que
brotes poeta generar anualmente durante
los últimos 30 años es Ficción incorrecta y
acelerar si servo para un descanso
inicio temporal de la pandemia del repollo
entonces no es ver a Elaine El pasado es
1990l de sobre el estilo cayó lgs de
octubre hefferon este año estaremos
viviendo creído desde el viento cada
Regla según la Huella Global y
sobre lo que se calcula dividiendo es
biocapacidad del planeta por ley para
humanidad ecologica sinenbargo
esta metodología es cuestionada
por los científicos afirmando que él
cálculo en también 50 años y recursos
minerales Nilce especies necesarias para
la bonita biodiversidad que se ofrecía
los plásticos con sus hijos y en el
mercado cuando él allí Oh y poner
que se joda el que se mete en la capacidad de
absorción de res
para ver el único residuo a ser mientras es
dulce sensible y luego otro recibo creo
si ocurren son dolor los dejo ser
Frío, no sé qué tan inteligente fue también
el dinero intenta entrar y ni el mundo antes
del todo y no en países específicos
él y ella severidad del problema este
el mapa muestra los países que conozco
chica cuales son los recursos naturales
los de verde Quítatelo y cámbialo
recibir la capacidad para unos pocos
a pesar de sus intersecciones científicas
eliader sobre seguir a Zig entiendo
Su propósito es alertar al público sobre la
importancia de ahorrar recursos
natural de la tia